في الجزائر مسلسل الدراما الاجتماعيه
الدامه اللي بيعرض على التلفزيون الجزائري
وبيتكلم عن الصراعات في احد احياء العاصمه
هذا المسلسل المتصدر الاخبار والسبب اصدار
سلطه ضبط او سلطه الضبط السمعي او ضبط
السمعي البصري بيان طالبت في التلفزيون
الحكومي بتوضيحات عن مشهد في اولى حلقات
المسلسل المشهد المقصود في البيان هو مشهد
بيظهر في جدار باحد اسواق الجزائر العاصمه
مكتوب عليه كلمه الماك
يمكن لغير الجزائريين مو واضح فين المشكله
في الكلمه المشكله انه الماك هو اسم لحركه
تقرير المصير في منطقه القبائل وتسمى ايضا
حركه الماء وهي منظمه سياسيه بتسعى للحكم
الذاتي والانفصال لاقليم القبائل في
الجزائر وتاسست عام 2001 وصنفتها الحكومه
الجزائريه في 2020 حركه ارهابيه فلما
الناس لاحظت ظهور الكلمه وصار الجدل قامت
السلطات وطالبت التلفزيون الحكومي بتوضيح
وقال انه راح تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه بناء
على التوضيحات اللي رح يقدمها التلفزيون
الجزائري الي للان ما في منه اي رد
[موسيقى]